all right new week and before we get
started i think the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
morning brew morning brew is a free
monday through sunday daily newsletter
that gets you up to speed on all your
business news and does it in five
minutes or less that's kind of that's
how i treat life i treat life like a
movie trailer i'm like give it to me in
five minutes or less so i'm i'm out and
then having their finger on the pulse of
business i love the fact that i can get
my crypto news from morning brew crypto
we've seen a bump recently awesome that
means i got some of my money back
i haven't broken even i got some of my
money back to 100k come on baby so if
you're interested in business finance or
tech i got your back it takes seconds to
subscribe to in key point like i said
before it's free i love free free is
always a great price so click the link
in the description to subscribe to
morning brew today and thank you once
again to morning brew for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it all right
now let's review a movie did you ever
watch and review a movie and think why
am i even reviewing this how many people
are going to watch this video what 7
17
max for you seven to 17 people this
one's for you that's why i do what i do
try to have fun with my reviews
entertain you if you're not even gonna
watch the movie so let's do it
[Music]
so the protege is a spy thriller that
seems like it came out of nowhere
because i saw zero trailers for it i saw
no marketing i don't know if you did
stars maggie q michael keaton samuel l
jackson and
here we go samuel l jackson's character
is a hitman who found maggie q's
character when she was a child and
trained her to be a great assassin feel
like you've seen it before rifle just
wait then her mentor samuel l jackson's
character gets killed so now she's
following the breadcrumbs it's a spy
thriller where she's trying to go to the
top find out who was behind this taking
out anyone in her path you still feel
like you've seen it before
right so did i and there are some movies
out there that give you that sensation
of like i've seen this a million times
before and i've seen it done better that
just it's easy to write off the thing
that makes this movie different and more
frustrating is the fact that there's
actually stuff to like in this movie
this mess of a movie there are things
that stand out first of all maggie q i
thought was great it's maggie q and
michael keaton i mean samuel l jackson
too but he's not in the movie much
samuel l jackson has gotten to the point
that many actors work their entire
lifetimes to get to granted he's worked
his entire lifetime to get to this point
where studios will write big checks just
to have him in the movie for that long
so he can put his name in the poster
easy money done like good for him and he
actually uses the time given to him in
this movie really well he has some
really good dialogue he's got good
snappy dialogue as does maggie q and
michael keaton what i liked about them
is initially when they meet they have
this flirty banter this dialogue michael
keaton's super charming and suave has
all the right things to say maggie q's
equally charming sexy and suave and has
all the right responses and things to
say it's the kind of flirting i wish i
could do because my flirting's like
pretty and that's it like i know i don't
have game i wish i had this kind of game
that flirty sexy banter back and forth
actually kept the movie going for me
it's what i loved most in this movie
yeah nothing to do with guns nothing to
do with following the breadcrumbs
nothing to do with the investigation no
spy [ __ ] kind of funny that the best
tension in this spy thriller was the
sexual tension other tension spy
thriller tension not really i mean they
try but now i knew this movie was gonna
have a tension problem in that respect
when at the beginning well near the
beginning of the movie maggie q does a
job she's driving away and the camera's
on her face she's like yeah i'm a badass
and then these goons are just behind her
vehicle shooting at her vehicle and the
rear window blows out so not bulletproof
glass bullets are flying by her head
she's just like yeah i'm a badass like
dude you're not invincible you need to
duck but she just didn't give a [ __ ]
it's like what are you a robot are you a
goddess well
i'm not gonna say maggie q's not a
goddess but i'm just saying unless
you're one of those two things [ __ ]
duck and cover it remind me of when
tough guys walk away from explosions
behind them only instead of an explosion
is bullets flying by your head granted
when tough guys walk away from
explosions there could always be
shrapnel that just but i don't always
think about that but bullets fresh on my
mind i'd love to see someone actually do
this in a movie and have it go down
exactly how it probably would have gone
down
had some cool scenes though which is
different than tension but there were
actually some pretty slick scenes of
executions i see moments like that like
fatalities and some of the mortal kombat
games that weren't as good i can still
enjoy those also maggie q is great for a
role like this i mean it's not her first
spy thriller at all she's got more spy
thrillers ahead of her i have no doubt
about that i just i hope the spy
thrillers she's in going forward don't
give me that sensation of like yeah i've
seen this when i read the synopsis and
some of that lack of tension does come
from the editing there were a couple of
edits where i was like that ended too
quickly or cut away to something else
and that scene was just half as long as
it probably should have been one scene
where i was like okay you could draw
that out or not it's it's done now okay
oh why not let's just get to the end i'm
not gonna say the thing i usually say
about movies where i say oh the movie
was a bit too long because it wasn't too
long i'll give it that i mean the
protege is directed by martin campbell
who directed casino royale which is
still top tier james bond movie but he's
also directed some garbage so you know
he he's 50 50. this movie felt like he
was seasoned enough to be like okay i
know what works i know what doesn't i'm
going to take elements of both of those
and combine them into a movie that by
the end people will be like yeah
that movie came out
that's right forgot it feels like i'm
bagging on the movie a lot sure i didn't
hate it it's there were things i enjoyed
in it and it was the actors chemistry
together and the dialogue they had i saw
it and it's not like i'm gonna go to my
friends and be like hey you gotta see
this you're looking for a spy thriller
this i wouldn't recommend it to friends
i don't think alcohol is gonna help it
so it sounds worse than i mean it to
sound but i'm just saying i'm not gonna
remember this movie in team minus well
i'll say two days yeah i already forgot
or i'll forget tomorrow anyway all right
so the pro today are you gonna watch are
you kind of curious at this point i
forgot what august movies feel like i
was like oh yeah august that's when
they're like yeah summer's over and
this stuff came out right so have you
seen this movie what did you think about
it or what's a great spy thriller for
you what's one of your favorites out
there whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you